today I want to talk about thinking
bigger so it's my book write a name a
little bit frustrated I'm frustrated
because I'm half an hour behind on my
walk the whole food so going right my
book because this morning I had a run-in
with one of my mentees I'm part of this
program through enterprise Toronto which
helps connect young entrepreneurs with
mentors and actually turned down a whole
bunch of mentors sorry mentees because
you know I love helping entrepreneurs I
love giving back for you guys watching
channel you know that's true but what I
where I spend my personal time my extra
time you know if I'm going to be doing
it mentoring somebody I want to make
sure that we're not just building a
regular business that we're not just you
know giving something to help you earn
an income but we're doing something
powerful to change the world right
everything else I try to do at scale
YouTube videos newsletters books that
kind of stuff but man one-on-one time
you got to know that's a premium for me
and we have to be doing something bigger
that is going to change the world and I
turned down a number of people had first
means with them and you know great
business ideas but just didn't have the
the drive to want to do something really
huge you know motivated just by paying
off their bills and making some money
and that's not what I'm interested in so
I found these two guys that I'm
connecting with and I've been getting
increasingly frustrated by what they've
been posting and i was looking at their
twitter feed and just posting stuff that
wasn't related to their core message and
i wrote to one of the founders today
that's what caused this whole lateness
this morning and he was trying to
basically just rank for search terms on
twitter and guys that is not the game to
play and i understand that you know that
might be the training and conditioning
that you you've been you grew up with
with marketing 101 but just ranking for
search is not going to help you because
it has to be relevant and you have to
have something that you stand for the
people care about right brand should
always be first brand should be always
above search I'm not seeing ignore
search I don't send ignore hashtags but
you don't do that
as a secondary thing to your brand what
you staying for has to be the first
thing and so I challenged them on it and
he's he felt like it was too big an idea
in that he wasn't sure how to explain it
to people and brought up you know how
much personal stuff do I share as part
of my brand and brought up the
chick-fil-a example where they came out
against gay marriage is that this is
really bad and first of all I agree
right you know I I don't think people
should be against gay marriage I don't
get it but a lot I understand a lot of
people do and you look at chick-fil-a
and now this guy is not going to
chick-fil-a anymore because of their
stance but chick-fil-a has grown
chick-fil-a takes these stains because
they feel it's important they don't let
people work on Sundays because they feel
that's important they lose it lose an
insane amount of business because
they're closed on Sundays and they stand
up against gay marriage for what they
feel is the right thing to do and even
though that alienates a lot of people it
brings people to them and builds an
insanely loyal audience right and
they've grown in the bigger than KFC now
and KFC's International chick-fil-a is
nowhere near as big we don't even have
them in Canada I don't believe but
there's tons of KFC so how do they do
that because they stand for something
right because they're different and so
you have to figure out what that is that
you stand for and there's no there's no
one right stance the key is figuring out
what it is that you want to make a
powerful positive impact on the world
with because people will drive an extra
5 10 20 miles to get to a chick-fil-a
and pass by 10 McDonald's along the way
because that's where they want to go and
I want that for your business man I
don't want you to just be like everybody
else competing on price and creating on
features and penile benefits and being a
boring business and as soon as your
competitor drops your price by five or
ten points they're going to jump ship
and go to them I want people to want to
drive an extra 50 miles to come to your
business I want people to take trips and
book a flight to come and buy from you
because you stand for something
extremely powerful and meaningful so
what is that if you don't like what
chick-fil-a stands for that's awesome
that's your prerogative be chick-fil-a
in a positive way because now they're
not just selling chicken burgers
they're selling a lifestyle they're
selling values and that's the step up
that's the bigger picture so you start
with the features you move the benefits
and the companies that get it the
companies that are building movements
comers that a change in the world they
move on to sell what they believe is
their core value and it has to start
around the core value that is important
to you so I'm frustrated but I think at
the end of the facebook conversation
with him we got it I hope I hope because
that's half an hour less time writing
the book help an impact all you guys who
are going to be able to read it and so I
hope that that one-on-one time left an
impact and makes a difference ok get to
some questions skunk fu 25 that's a
crazy name man writes in Evin for
president 2016 yeah that's an
interesting one I don't know if I'd ever
run for politics is something that I've
thought about a number of times I don't
know if I can handle the bureaucracy and
the politics of politics my mother was a
politician and so I have kind of an
inside view of how that entire world
works but I can't be President because
I'm Canadian and that's a rule so there
might be some office I don't know
sometime in the distant future but right
now i'm loving what I'm doing but I
appreciate the suggestion man it means a
lot next up bow i'm currently 15 and
from belgium i have a big idea that
would help people selling online i
really made the site i'm on my own I
need a couple friends that helped me
with the start so there won't be any
delay with for the customers sadly none
are interested in earning a bit of money
and helping me out maybe it's because
I'd rather watch Netflix or something
else is there way to motivate younger
people and it's not why there's a great
question and honestly has nothing to do
with younger people or not people say
young people are lazy they're not most
people are lazy most people are lazy
because they have goals that don't
inspire them or they believe that those
goals are not achievable because they
have an environment that holds them back
that's the truth I think the difference
for people who are adults will be they
have bills to pay and so they go and
they get a job and they're forced to go
and work in order to meet their
lifestyle needs we're younger people may
not if you're 15 you're living at home
you don't have huge expenses so you
don't need to go and get a job but just
because people gone out and get a job
that's just survival man they're still
lazy they still don't have goals that
inspire them and so I think that's the
key you know you need to have
big goals that make you want to get up
and do something and then a positive
environment that supports you towards
achieving those goals and look at you
you're off you're hustling you're 15
you're watching these videos you're
trying to make your dreams happen and so
my advice is to fold one for those of
you who are feeling like you want to do
something bigger like you want to have a
huge impact somehow the key is to change
your environment to surround yourself
with people motivation ideas that make
you come alive to watch the ants presso
series of top 10 series the other videos
other books other mentors that you can
learn from that force you to be the best
version of yourself like i did this
morning for that entrepreneur who was
thinking small because his environment
forces him to think small and I'm I'm
someone in his environment that forces
him to break free and challenges is
thinking so you need that and you may
not be able to get at one on one of the
people but you can get it from videos
and books and that's how I started just
by reading books and that challenge my
thinking that's how you for yourself
just motivating other people honestly I
wouldn't try honestly what I would try
to do is get people who are motivated
because it's hard to change a person if
you want to change yourself you want to
break free of all those limiting person
beliefs that's a long process and the
president how committed you are to it
right that does that doesn't just happen
overnight and part of your role as an
entrepreneur as a leader is to make the
people around you better and believe in
themselves more and give them more
opportunities and train them to be the
best thing and being whatever position
they have but it's a lot to take on and
when I work with people right when I
hire my team I've got 16 people on my
team right now I always scream to find
people who are already motivated and
have attention to detail and care about
the mission that we're on because if I
have to teach that as well I'm behind
the ball and so one if it's yourself and
you want to get better work on it if
it's your team I wouldn't hire somebody
then try to fix and change them yes you
can make some improvement but I would
try to hire people who already are
motivated and want to do this and want
to make the money
and want to grow and want to do
something important and don't just want
to sit there and watch Netflix last
question Alliance looking forward to
your book man the loyal subs get a
discount when was a probable release
date I appreciate that man I'm really
excited about the book to even just
thinking about it writing you're walking
the whole foods ago edit it I'm excited
by it crazy loud garbage truck going by
the Royal subs get a discount I don't
know what the publisher is going to want
to do with that but it's not going to be
that expensive a book you're getting
tons of free content every day on the
channel I think you can afford to drop a
little bit on one book to support me
come on guys I know you have my back on
that one and in terms of the release
date it's supposed to be in this January
so it's October now social begin by
January and then it's going to be
released likely next January okay so
you've got time I've got time to get it
out to market it you've got time to
watch his videos turn it into something
that creates an amazing business for you
and then you can go buy a thousand
copies as a thank you instead of just
one and asking for a discount right bro
right feeling me all right thank you
guys for the awesome episode great
questions if you have a question about
my book the book writing process the top
of today of thinking bigger leaving the
comments below and I will answer it in
next week's episode have an amazing day
I'll see you guys see believe